una computadora puede hacer el trabajo
de cinco mil personas ordinarios
pero ninguna computadora puede ser
trabajo de una persona extraordinaria
esta frase por el verdugo que escuche
más bien la ley y al enterarme de este
evento dije pues si eso podría ser un
buen tema pero seguiré buscando sobre
otras cosas algo que me atrapará mi
atención
pero volviendo a frase
siempre volví esa frase al punto que la
repetía en mi mente y empecé a repetir
en voz alta
y ahí me llegó
una cachetada podría decirlo
la frase tiene razón porque es cero
alguien ordinario común y corriente
cuando podría ser algo más algo que
sabes que puede ser así que les voy a
contar lo que yo creo que es la verdad
les contaré de un joven jack andraca
qaeda de los 15 años descubrió un
software que detecta el cáncer en 5
minutos
de inventar
yo tengo 16 años y te han hecho nada con
mi vida
otra persona mala la ayuda de una joven
qaeda de 23 años en un blog medio por
los derechos de las mujeres en su país
natal pakistán porque no reciben una
educación
y claro podría estar hablando de otras
personas el movimiento de las
sufragistas martin luther king junior o
jean louis
mujeres y hombres que decidieron hacer
un cambio extraordinario
y tal vez hay una persona aquí en esta
audiencia que diga sí pero no voy a
poder ser una persona como martín
oferting eso es una persona sin nada más
entra en un en un millón verdad
eso era lo que yo quería
ahora les contaré algo de mí yo soy
disléxico personas que no sepan que es
la dislexia es como una barrera que
tiene tu mente algo que se te complica
hacer y demasiado
a mí bueno personal se me complica la
escuela y enfocarme
me enteré de esto y dije pues aquí quedó
mi vida ya no voy a poder hacer nada
voy a estar atorado en el mismo lugar
hasta que mi mamá me dijo que no que te
puede si te esfuerzas puedes hacer lo
que tú quieras tiene las mismas
oportunidades que en este planeta
y escuché y dije tiene razón si les doy
mi 150 por ciento en todo lo que hago
podría ser lo que yo quiera
miren dónde estoy
si no hubiera sido por todo este
esfuerzo tal vez no estaría parado aquí
hoy
y todo ese esfuerzo que he hecho por
casi toda mi vida ha sido reconocido
hace un año recibió una carta de tal vez
una de las universidades más
prestigiosas de eeuu
stanford university
esa carta decía que me invitaban a
participar ir a su campus estudiar por
dos semanas con todos sus maestros y
tener la experiencia de una universidad
americana
estoy en una posición donde tuve la
oportunidad de ir
estos maestros me abrieron a nuevos
horizontes cosas que antes no podía ver
y las personas que me acompañaron porque
no fui solo
me han cambiado la vida
con esto les quiero dejar hoy que aunque
piensen que tal vez no van a poder hacer
lo que quieren audita y jóvenes
presentes de mi generación primera
secundaria son de secundaria hasta
primaria que se digan pues estoy
demasiado joven para empezar esto mi
idea no es muy buena o que nadie me va a
escuchar
no
si te pones a hacer lo que tú quieras
hacer y le das todo puedes hacerlo
aunque te intenten aunque haya personas
allí porque va a haber personas que
tengan tirar
y te entierran con todas estas mentiras
levantate con todas tus fuerzas mira
hacia el cielo con esperanza y tus pies
plantados en la tierra
y recuerda que si puedes que yo sí puedo
y esa es la verdad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]